SUSANNAH GIBSON: Well, thank
you very much, Christina.
And thank you, everyone.
I'm just going to move
this, because I can't really
see your faces.
Thank you so much for
coming along today.
Right, so my talk
today is titled
"Animal, Vegetable, Mineral."
And let's start
off with a picture.
Does anyone know what these are?
AUDIENCE: Corals.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Yeah, corals.
Exactly.
And do you know if coral
is an animal, a vegetable,
or a mineral?
AUDIENCE: Animal.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Wow,
you guys are good.
But how did you know that?
What is it that makes
coral an animal?
There aren't any right
or wrong answers.
It's history.
It's not science,
so just shout out.
AUDIENCE: It's
made up of polyps.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SUSANNAH GIBSON: So you're
just taking that one step back.
So what makes a polyp an
animal, would you say?
AUDIENCE: Sense of smell.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Yeah.
Again, there are
no wrong answers.
So anything you can think
of, just shout it out.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
photosynthesize.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Yeah,
that's a good one.
So you guys have given quite
a few different reasons there,
involving cells, photosynthesis,
and the polyp-y nature
of things, for saying that
something is an animal rather
than a plant or a mineral.
Now, the scientists
today are indeed
pretty certain,
pretty confident,
about saying that
corals are animals.
They're pretty certain
about classifying
lots of different things today.
But I want to talk about the
long and convoluted history
of that certainty, how
we got to that part,
and more interestingly,
I think, the fact
that when you start to pick
apart the certainty, things
become much more
tenuous, more uncertain,
there are more questions.
So I'm going to look at
some of the questions that
have been raised over
the history of people
asking questions like animal,
vegetable, or mineral.
These are questions like, how
do we know something's alive?
How do we know that an
animal really is an animal?
Does an animal have a soul?
Or, how is life created?
Now, this talk comes
with a slight disclaimer.
As Cristina mentioned,
I'm actually
a historian nowadays
rather than a scientist.
So I'm more interested in
seeing how people have answered
these questions
over the centuries
rather than in looking for
just one definitive answer.
So if you came here today
to find out whether or not
animals really have
souls and so on,
I may not be able to help you.
Put that out there.
OK, no one's left,
so that's excellent.
OK, so the first
question is, how do we
know something's alive?
Well, it's a good question.
Does anyone remember
the kind of things
you learned in school
when you covered
this in biology classes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Exactly, yeah.
The mnemonic we had at
school was Mrs. Gren.
So Mrs. Gren refers to movement,
respiration, sensation, growth,
reproduction, excretion,
and nutrition.
Now, those seven
things are said to be
the characteristics of life.
You probably all learned
about them in school.
But actually, a very
small percentage of life
forms exhibit all seven.
The system is a little bit crude
in that you can sort of pick
and choose how many
of the characteristics
must be displayed before
you decide that something
is or isn't alive.
So a crystal can grow, but
obviously it isn't alive.
A virus is really interesting.
It appears to be able to do
quite a lot of the things
on the list, but
it can't do them
without some help from a host,
so we don't really classify it
as being alive, either.
On the flip side, some things
exhibit fewer than seven
of the signs of life, but we
do consider them to be alive.
So most plants, for example,
don't display a huge amount
of sensitivity or motion--
locomotion, especially--
but we still classify
them as living beings.
So this system isn't perfect,
but it works reasonably well
for a lot of everyday purposes.
One of the reasons
that it works really
well is that it's been
perfected over many centuries.
In fact, this method
of distinguishing life
from non-life can be traced back
at least as far as Aristotle.
Now, Aristotle is known as a
great philosopher, obviously.
But nowadays, a lot of people
forget that he was also
a really great zoologist.
And actually, 25% of
his surviving writings
are about zoology.
We know that he wrote at least
five books about zoology,
covering the history of
animals, parts of animals,
generation of animals,
reproduction of animals--
I said that already--
movement of animals,
and progression of animals.
And we know from
references that he
himself made and contemporaries
made that Aristotle also
wrote books about plants,
although sadly, none of those
have survived.
But the animal books
talk about the qualities
that make animals animals.
So in order for something
to be classed as an animal,
Aristotle said that it
had to be able to move.
It had to be able to feel.
It had to be able to reproduce.
It needed some
sort of nutrition.
And it had to have blood or
something similar to blood,
and vessels to
contain that blood.
So you can see,
looking at this list,
that the first four of these
correspond pretty closely
to the modern requirement for
something to be called living.
So the definition of
life that I talked
about earlier with Mrs. Gren is
pretty close to the definition
of animal.
That's fair enough.
If something is moving
around, if it's having babies,
if it's eating, it's pretty easy
for us to say that it's alive.
But what about slightly
less lively entities?
What about things like plants?
Now interestingly, I
think, the word "vegetable"
comes from the Latin
"vegetus," or "way-ge-tus,"
as the cool kids in
Cambridge pronounce it--
which means there really
is a cool way in Cambridge
to pronounce Latin words.
It's true.
"Vegetus."
Let's say it that way, which
means "lively" or "vigorous."
Nowadays, they're not words we
apply to plants terribly often,
especially "lively."
But in a literal sense,
plant really is lively.
Plants clearly
exhibit at least three
of the seven signs of life.
You can easily see
that they grow.
They reproduce.
They need nourishment.
They also all respire,
although that wasn't known
about until the 18th century.
Some of them can feel,
and some of them can move.
Most biologists today
take it for granted
that plants are in fact alive.
In fact, that notion was built
into the definition of animal,
vegetable, or mineral
that dominated
the 18th- and 19th-century
life sciences,
and that same definition has
informed the list of seven
signs that we use today.
The definition runs [LATIN]
So it means that stones grow,
plants grow and live, and
animals grow, live, and feel.
Like I said, this
definition is the one
that really dominated the
18th- and 19th-centuries.
This particular
way of phrasing was
coined by Carl Linnaeus,
who you may have heard of.
He was famous for his biological
classification systems,
as well as for inventing
the binomial nomenclature
that people still
use today-- so things
like home sapiens
and boa constrictor,
those sort of two-part names.
So Linnaeus defined life as
being a particular property
of plants and animals.
So does this mean that you have
to define an animal or plant
before you know what life is?
Which kind of leads
to another question,
which is, how do we know
that something actually
is an animal or a plant?
So that brings us onto
the next question.
How do we know that an
animal really is an animal?
Well, sure, it's pretty easy
to distinguish between, say,
an elephant and a tree.
That's straightforward enough.
But how do you decide
about something that's
a bit more ambiguous, something
like a sponge or a coral,
or an oyster, even?
These things don't look like
they do much moving around.
They don't seem
terribly sensitive.
And it's tricky, at least
with naked-eye observations,
to tell whether they
really eat or excrete.
So now we consider
all of these things
I just mentioned to be
animals-- sponges and corals
and oysters-- but at
different periods of history,
they've also been classed
as vegetables or minerals.
Or commonly, they're classed
as a member of a fourth group,
the zoophytes.
And zoophyte is a Greek word
that means "animal-plant."
And this was going to be
sort of an intermediary place
where you could put
things between the animal
and the plant kingdoms when they
didn't really fit into either.
So the sea sponge
is a really good--
that yellow thing over
there is a sea sponge.
That's a really good
example of a zoophyte.
Now, one of the earliest written
descriptions of the sea sponge
comes from Aristotle's book,
"The History of Animals."
Now, Aristotle wasn't
just a theorist.
He actually spent
an awful lot of time
doing zoological research.
In the 340s BC, he left Athens
and he spent about two decades
on the cost of what
we now call Turkey
and on the island of Lesbos
studying marine creatures,
especially.
Now, marine life is one of the
most difficult to classify,
because a lot of these creatures
display some properties that
seem like they belong
to a plant and some
that seem like they should
belong to an animal.
So in the case of the
sponge, because of the way
sponges anchor themselves
to rocks or to surfaces,
they were believed for
an awfully long time
to have roots like
a planet does.
But Aristotle noticed
one significant way
in which sponges were
a lot like animals.
He said that if you tried to
pluck a sponge off a rock,
it will cling more
tightly to the rock
if it senses you coming.
But if you sneak up on the
sponge, said Aristotle,
you can more easily
remove it from its perch.
So as far as our
Aristotle was concerned,
the sponge could experience
some kind of sensation,
and so it was maybe
an intermediate life
form between the plant kingdom
and the animal kingdom.
Now, a huge number of organisms
fall into this category--
things like corals,
which we saw earlier,
all those green things,
sponges, starfish,
sea urchins, earthworms,
just to name a couple.
Because of their strange
nature, zoophytes
raise an awful lot of
important questions.
How do we define a plant?
How do we define an animal?
What's the relationship
between the two kingdoms?
Is there maybe some
kind of chain that
connects all living things?
Now, for centuries
after Aristotle
wrote about sneaking
up on sponges.
Naturalists debated where the
boundary between the kingdoms
lay.
And the debate really
peaked in the 18th century,
which is what I'm mostly
going to talk about today.
Why the 18th century?
Well, there's a couple
of significant factors.
First, the Enlightenment culture
that was sweeping across Europe
at this time really promoted
an interest in science
and encouraged people to try
out scientific experiments
and observations for themselves.
It was a very hands-on movement.
And second,
improvements in things
like the manufacture of
scientific instruments
like microscopes meant that they
were becoming better and more
affordable, so more people
could get their hands on them
and use them.
So it was in this
enlightenment culture
that a man named Abraham
Trembley-- there he is--
began studying a little creature
known as the freshwater polyp,
or nowadays more often
called the hydra.
In 1741, Trembley
published his findings
about this polyp, which
you can see on your right.
And his results
caused consternation
all across the scientific
circles of Europe.
There is a little bit of
background about Trembley.
So he was born in the
Republic of Geneva.
He was educated
there before moving
to Leiden in the
Netherlands to continue
studying at the university.
But after a little
while in Leiden,
he was offered a
position as tutor
to the sons of a local
count who happened
to live near the Hague.
He lived at the count's
estate for almost a decade,
and it was there in the
1730s, but in the second half
of the 1730s, that he
began to research polyps.
Now, what's a polyp,
I hear you all cry.
I'm sure at least one
person was thinking that.
So a polyp is a little creature.
You can see one
there on the right.
It's generally less than
a centimeter in length.
They're often shaped like
bells, or in the description
more often used by
18th-century naturalists,
like the severed
finger of a glove.
So it has a single opening which
is surrounded by tentacles,
and that opening leads
to a central cavity.
They're usually found
in stagnant ditches
or similar locations.
And for Trembley, living
in the Netherlands,
there were an
awful lot of canals
and stagnant water
around him, so he
was able to find an awful lot.
In fact, this is a picture from
a book he published in 1744.
You can see him down
in the bottom left
of the picture looking for
polyps in one of the ponds
at the count's estate.
And the two little
children there
are the children
he was a tutor to,
Jean and Antoine,
who accompanied him
on an awful lot of his
polyp-hunting expeditions,
and actually helped him do
a lot of his observations,
which is quite sweet.
So with a little bit of help
from these two young boys,
Trembley became really
expert at finding polyps,
but more importantly, keeping
them alive in captivity.
So he spent a lot
of time figuring out
what they liked to eat
and what kind of water
they like to live in, and
whether they liked sunshine
or darkness, and so on.
It was quite difficult to keep
them alive for long enough
to do what he needed to do.
But once he had
figured this out,
he would spend hours observing
them and performing experiments
on them.
And from his observations
and his experiments
came his most famous
finding, the one
I mentioned earlier
that shocked Europe.
This resulted from a very simple
experiment in which Trembley
just cut a polyp in
two and then watched
as each half regenerated into
a perfect and fully functioning
replica of the parent.
So again, that
picture on the right,
which is marked Figure 13, is
one of his drawings of a polyp
that he's just cut.
And from that cup
will bud out-- I
guess you could argue
I put these slides
in the wrong order-- will bud
out lots of new polyps, which
will each grow
into perfect, fully
functioning, grownup adult
polyp and become independent
of its parent.
Now, part of Trembley's reason
for undertaking this experiment
was to determine whether polyps
were animal or vegetable.
Differences in the way
that animals and vegetables
reproduced meant that, according
to the definition of the time,
plants could regrow from
cuttings but animals could not.
So when the cut polyps
regenerated their lost parts,
that should have allowed
Trembley to place them
in the vegetable kingdom.
But some of their
other properties
marked them out as
animal, at least
according to Aristotle's
definition, which was still
pretty standard at this time.
So the first animal-like
property that polyps displayed
was movement of their tentacles.
In water, their tentacles
moved independently
of any motion in the liquid.
The second animal-like
property was that they
were sensitive to the touch.
So if you touched a polyp
or shook the jar it was in,
it would contract its tentacles.
Third, Aristotle had
suggested that the presence
of a mouth and a stomach were
central to the definition
of an animal.
And Trembley had seen
polyps grasping food
with their tentacles and placing
it in their central cavity,
so he could prove, according
to Aristotle's definition,
that the polyp was
probably an animal.
Another reason to
view polyps as animals
was their power of locomotion.
So polyps were
capable of traveling
in two different ways.
So this picture on the
top, Figures 1 to 4,
you can see a sort
of inchworm-like way
they have of moving.
So they lie on their bellies,
they scrunch themselves out
and they flatten
themselves out again,
and they can move
themselves along that way.
The lower one is one of
the most fantastic forms
of transport in the animal
kingdom in the world.
They somersault. They stand
up, they put their tentacle end
down, they put their
non-tentacle end up,
and they flip themselves
over like that, which I
think is absolutely wonderful.
And when Trembley saw this, he
also thought it was amazing.
He spent hours
watching them do this.
[LAUGHTER]
And that was one of the things
that really convinced him
that the polyp
must be an animal.
That just didn't seem like
something a plant would do.
On Aristotle's final definition
of an animal, which was about
whether or not they have
blood, Trembley's results
were inconclusive.
He did find some
green liquid in them,
but he wasn't sure if
it was really blood.
But according to
Aristotle's five criteria,
the polyp was an animal in
the way it took nutrition,
in the way it moved, and
in the way it could feel.
It was a vegetable in
the way it reproduced,
and it was sort of ambivalent
with the question about blood.
So Trembley didn't know what to
make of this strange creature,
so he just kept repeating
his experiments over and over
until he convinced himself
that all of his results
were in fact true.
When he was sure
and when he finally
had enough proof as he thought
to convince other people,
he sent a report of his findings
to a Frenchman called Reaumur.
And Reaumur was a
really important figure
at Paris's prestigious
Academy of Sciences,
and he would later go on
to become its president,
and he was also an
expert on insect biology.
Now, Reaumur, like Trembley,
was completely astonished.
And in true
Enlightenment spirit,
he decided to
investigate for himself.
So Trembley sent some live
specimens of polyps to Reaumur.
He hadn't yet figured out a good
way to transport them alive,
so they had to be
carried at walking pace
from Leiden to Paris on
horseback in an open container,
obviously going no faster
than a slow walk, which
took quite a while.
But once they
arrived, Reaumur was
able to have a go at
Trembley's experiments
and fully replicated
all of his results.
So having finally confirmed
Trembley's results,
Reaumur published an account
of Trembley's experiment
and his findings in the
scientific journal, "Histoire
de l'Academie des
Sciences," which
was the big French science
journal of the day.
And that account,
which was perhaps
a little bit over
the top, compared
the polyp to a phoenix
being reborn from the ashes,
caused a huge, huge
stir in Europe.
It was read by
thousands of people,
and almost overnight, everyone,
not just elite scientists,
began talking about this.
And as soon as the
results were out there,
Trembley was inundated
with letters demanding
clarifications and
proofs and live specimens
to be carried by
very slow horses.
He did later get better
at transporting specimens
in little sealed boxes.
But it wasn't just
the scientific elite
that were reading
about Trembley's works.
The initial account, along with
passages from Trembley's book,
which came out a
couple of years later,
was reprinted in
the popular press.
It was translated into a
bunch of different languages.
It was pirated and
plagiarized, which
are two really good signs
of how popular it was.
Being plagiarized or
pirated is actually
a good mark of success.
But people weren't just
reading about Trembley's work.
They were also replicating it.
Trembley was really
generous with his polyps,
and once he got better
at transporting them
he sent an awful lot of
specimens to other naturalists
all across Europe.
But polyps and
zoophytes were pretty
easy to find, actually, like
I said, in ponds and ditches,
by the seashore.
So even if you
didn't know Trembley,
you could try out these sorts
of experiments for yourself.
And because it was the
height of the Enlightenment,
an awful lot of
people actually did.
You can see the impact
of Trembley's work
in scientific journals,
but also in pop culture.
Polyps are always showing up
in poems and songs and satires
in this period.
All across society,
they're popping up.
But I suppose the question is,
why were they such a big deal?
There were huge.
So it's pretty cool,
sure, that something might
be half-animal and half-plant.
There is a picture of some cool
things that are half-animal,
half-plant.
That's Animal-Vegetable-Mineral
Man from DC Comics,
and that's that guy from
"The Little Shop of Horrors."
Did he have a name?
I'm not sure if he did.
But there's more to it, really,
than some creatures that
just have interesting biology.
Once you start studying
things like polyps,
you go pretty quickly from
asking questions like,
can it sense, can it
move, to questions like,
if I cut an animal in two
and if each half becomes
an individual animal, is that
some kind of creation event?
Is God involved?
And actually, how
is life generated?
Now, Trembley
himself didn't want
to get too involved in
the philosophical debates,
but lots of other people did.
And that brings us to a
third question, which is,
does an animal have a soul?
Now, when Reaumur had
published Trembley's results,
he ended his account by saying
that those results might
be used to answer questions
about how animals reproduce
and how they're
related to plants.
But then he sort of trailed
off with a suggestion
that they may also tell
us something about what
he called higher matters.
Now, a lot of
readers at the time
would have known exactly what
Reaumur was referring to.
He was talking about one of
the key ideological clashes
of the Enlightenment,
and that was
a standoff between
materialism and vitalism.
So materialism
essentially is the belief
that all that exists in the
world is matter or more energy.
This is a philosophy that
goes back as far as the Greeks
and the Romans, people like
Epicurious and Lucretius.
Lucretius especially
is associated
with the idea of
atomism, which is
the belief that
the world contains
only atoms and the
spaces between them.
And on the other
side of the debate
stirred vitalism, which
says that there's something
special about living matter.
You can't just
reduce it to atoms
and the spaces between them.
But I'll come back
to vitalism later.
Now, in the 17th
and 18th centuries,
materialism was a really big
idea in the life sciences,
thanks especially to the work
of one man, Rene Descartes.
Now, Descartes had proposed
idea of the animal machine.
The animal machine
was a living-- I mean,
according to Descartes' theory,
we're all animal machines.
Every animal is a mini-machine.
They conform to a
particular pattern.
They function just
like clockwork
or any other mechanical system.
According to Descartes, it
had been designed by God.
And one final thing you need to
know about the animal machine
is that, although the
physical body worked just
like a machine, there was
a nonmaterial soul which
could act independently
of the laws of nature.
This separation of body and
soul was called dualism,
and it allowed Descartes
fit the theory in better
with the religious
orthodoxy of the day.
But suddenly, with
Trembley's polyp experiments,
there were some problems
for the theory of the animal
as a machine made by God.
First, the matter
within the polyp
could regrow itself
when it was cut.
So did that mean that it had
some kind of active property,
something independent of God?
Second, if material itself had
the power to create new life,
did polyp generation
count as a creation event
without any input from God?
Third, if God was
dispensable here,
was he dispensable elsewhere?
And in the 18th century, that's
quite a dangerous question
to find yourself asking.
And fourth, if you
cut a polyp in two,
and if each part regrows into
a fully functioning individual,
was the soul split in two?
Did the soul then regrow
in each new polyp?
There were some
pretty big questions
that come from just one
really simple experiment.
But some of the hardcore
materialists had a solution.
There was a French
philosopher called
La Mettrie who believed
that the soul was not
distinct from the matter
that made up a living being.
So if that was the
case, then it was
impossible to separate
matter and the soul.
The division of the polyp
into two or more parts
but without the
loss of life seemed
to prove that the soul was
actually inherent in matter,
and furthermore, that
the soul was divisible.
Just think about
that for a second.
It's a little bit
Harry Potter, actually.
So La Mettrie took this
idea one step further
in a book which he published in
1748, called "L'homme Machine,"
"The Man as Machine."
This was published just a few
years after Trembley's book
on polyps, and it suggested that
not only was the animal's soul
a function of matter,
but that this also might
be true of the human soul.
Now, needless to say, this
wasn't a terribly popular
position with the Christian
churches, which pointed out
that it was dangerous
to try and determine
the nature of the soul
from scientific experiments
rather than through the words of
scripture or divine revelation.
But despite some
religious objection,
materialism really was
flourishing at this time.
And it was especially
popular in the salons
of Enlightenment Paris.
And one salon in
particular stood out
as a hotbed of materialism,
that of a man named the Baron
d'Holbach.
In 1770, he
published anonymously
a treatise that used scientific
findings from previous decades
to argue that there was
no such thing as God,
no such things as a soul, just
matter obeying physical laws.
So from Trembley's experiment
where he cut up a polyp,
people were saying there
was no such thing as god.
So materialists are making
pretty big arguments
from something small.
But on the other side, people
were arguing in favor-- sorry,
ignore that-- of a vitalism,
which I mentioned earlier.
So vitalism is
another philosophy
with very ancient
roots, and it states
that there is something
special about living matter.
It has some kind of
quality that makes
it different from
nonliving matter.
And a living being was
not, no matter what
the materialists said--
and the French materialists
in particular, who
were the worst-
just a collection of particles.
Life wasn't just
something that obeyed
physical and chemical laws.
It was special.
It had a spirit, or it had a
vital force, that distinguished
it from inanimate objects.
Now, vitalism had been
around for a long time,
but it also became
a little bit more
visible in the 17th and 18th
centuries as a direct response
to the views of
people like Descartes.
And while materialists
like La Mettrie
argued that the
regeneration of the polyps
showed that the soul was not
an ethereal spirit but just
a function of matter, vitalists
like the German scientist
Blumenbach disagreed.
At the end of the 18th
century, Blumenbach,
who was familiar
with Trembley's work,
cut up polyps himself and
watched as they regenerated.
And from his work,
he developed a theory
of formative drive
and vital forces.
He believed that the
regeneration of polyps
showed that there really was a
vital force in living tissues.
But like a lot of
other vitalists,
he was a little bit cagey about
exactly what that force was.
So you can see that
using the same results,
naturalists were
arguing both for
and against the
existence of the soul.
It hadn't really been
Trembley's intention
to raise such big
questions, he just
wanted to know whether polyps
were animals or plants.
In case anyone's
wondering, polyps,
as I think you mentioned,
are now classed as animals.
They're pretty
cool, because they
contain absolutely enormous
numbers of stem cells, which
basically make them immortal.
So they're pretty popular
lab animals these days
for people working
on stem cells.
But back to the 18th century.
So we've seen how
looking at pond slime
and asking the question, animal,
vegetable, or mineral leads
to some difficult questions.
But where else can it take us?
So we've seen that one
of the interesting things
about the polyp was
the way it reproduced.
Unlike most animals, which
needed a mother and a father
to create offspring, a
polyp could just regenerate
from cuttings from its parent.
Which leads us to the
next question, which
is, how is life generated.
So people have been asking
that question for a long time.
There are a lot of
different answers.
Aristotle said that
when animals reproduced,
the mother supplied the matter
while the father supplied
the form, or the soul.
But when it came to things that
were less obviously animal,
like shellfish for
example, Aristotle
said that they
were spontaneously
generated by the earth
in which they lived.
And he said, depending on the
kind of soil that spawned them,
different creatures
would be produced.
So oysters grew from slimy mud,
cockles grew from sandy mud,
limpets grew from
rocks, and so on.
Now, since the cells involved
in animal reproduction
can be pretty small and
pretty difficult to see,
believing in things like
spontaneous generation
actually made a lot of
sense for a very long time.
Mammal eggs weren't discovered
until the 19th century.
The human egg wasn't seen
until the 20th century.
So again, back to
the 18th century,
the polyp reinforced the idea
that spontaneous generation
might just be possible
and prompted people
to ask questions about
how reproduction worked.
People wanted to know
what kind of forces
drove the creation of life.
They wanted to know how
matter became alive.
They wanted to know what role
God played in reproduction,
and they wanted to know
how features passed down
the generations of a family.
Now, at this time, there
were two particularly
common explanations for
how reproduction worked.
The first was a system
called preformation.
Preformation held that
all living creatures
had been created by God at
the beginning of the world.
Everything that would ever
live through all ages of time
was created at the same
time, thousands and thousands
of years ago, then each being
was folded up in serial order
and nested inside its parent.
So God sort of created a
series of Russian dolls.
The original parent contained
the germ of every single child
that would ever be produced
in the family line,
and at the appointed
time, each germ
would develop into
a seed or a fetus
and would then grow
into its mature form.
Now, this theory
obviously raised
some logistical questions,
but it dealt kind of neatly
with two of the
big problems posed
by the science of reproduction.
First, it allowed God to keep
his central role in creation.
Each being was made
directly by his hand.
And second, it fitted with
a popular 18th-century view
of God, which saw
him as a creator who
had set the whole
universe in motion
and was now sort of happy to sit
back and let it run according
to the laws that he had made
for it-- sort of like clockwork,
which was quite a popular
analogy in the 18th century.
And if that was
the case, it meant
that God didn't have to
oversee every single individual
creation event that happened
in the plant and animal
kingdoms, which would be
pretty time-consuming.
In stark contrast to
preformation theory, which
fitted quite well with orthodox
Christian views of the time,
stirred something
called epigenesis.
Epigenesis said
that all new life
was generated from the
gradual development
of disorganized matter.
Each embryo received
was created uniquely
due to the laws of chemistry and
physics acting on inert matter.
Unlike preformation theory,
epigenesis did not necessarily
require any input from God.
It was a materialist, and
therefore quite radical,
theory, which could be
used to say that there
was no such thing
as a soul-- again,
just material obeying
physical laws.
So the theories drew
supporters or detractors
not just because of
their scientific content,
but also because of their
theological and philosophical
implications.
And one of the best
known examples of this
is a dispute between two
naturalists called Albrecht von
Haller, Caspar Friedrich
Wolff, who I'm going
to talk about a little bit now.
So the dispute
between these two men
illustrates that scientific
results can be just as much
about people's
agendas as they are
about finding the right
answer, which is still
true today, as anyone who has
ever worked in lab will know.
Haller-- he's on
the left-- was one
of the most impressive
polymaths of his day.
He was an anatomist, a
physiologist, a physician,
a botanist, a university
professor, a poet, a novelist,
a political and theological
author, a bibliographer,
a reviewer, an academician,
a civil servant,
and a politician.
Like Trembley, he was
Swiss, although he actually
worked in Germany as a
professor of anatomy, surgery,
and medicine.
When he was young, Haller had
studied in the Netherlands,
and he learned about
preformation theory
and accepted it as true.
But in the 1740s, when
he began to hear reports
of Trembley's
experiments, he thought
that perhaps the
ability of polyps
to regenerate missing
or injured parts
might mean that
generation occurred
in a way that could not be
explained by preformation
theory.
And so he began to
consider epigenesis.
But although Trembley's
polyps piqued his interest
in epigenesis, Haller couldn't
really accept the theory.
It was just too
atheistic for him.
He was a devout
Christian, and he
believed that science
was best carried out
within a religious framework.
For him, any
scientific theory that
could form a basis for
materialism or atheism
had to be rejected.
So he turned back to
preformation theory,
but a slightly modified
version of preformation theory
in which a force
called irritability
could take a minuscule,
preformed person
or plant or animal and set
its development in motion.
And this irritable
force, Haller said,
was bestowed upon matter by God.
He gave the example of a
preformed embryo contained
within its mother's body, which
was stimulated when it came
into contact with male semen.
In response, its
inherent irritability
caused the heart
to begin beating
and allowed the
rest of the embryo
to develop according
to God's design.
To add some credibility
to his new theory,
Haller began to observe the
development of chick eggs.
You can see some pictures on
the right there of dissections
of chick embryos, which
are actually by Wolff.
But as I'll say in a
minute, they basically
found the exact same thing.
So when Haller
looked at chick eggs,
he observed that, for the first
few days after fertilization,
the contents of an egg
appear to be entirely liquid,
and only later do solid
structures start to appear.
Now, a lot of people saw that
as evidence for epigenesis,
saying that out of the
liquid formed structures.
But Haller argued
that within the fluids
there actually were
structures, but they
were transparent, and therefore
invisible to the human eye.
He continued his observations
all through the 1750s,
and at the end of that
decade he published
a book containing all of his
observations, which he hoped
would proceed people to believe
in his version of preformation
theory.
But not everyone was convinced.
The following year, a
young German scholar--
he was a quite radical
man, called Wolff,
in the middle there-- published
his doctoral dissertation,
which was all about different
theories of generation.
Now, he made almost identical
observations on chick eggs
to Haller's, but he interpreted
his results very differently.
Wolff saw the development of
the chick in epigenetic terms.
He thought that there was
an essential force driving
the secretion of new matter,
which then solidified
a process which occurred
in serial order,
so that once one
organ was formed
it could secrete the matter
for the next organ, and so on.
He just relied on
physical and chemical laws
to show how liquid can
form into a tiny bird.
Haller and Wolff each made
careful, very detailed studies
of the chick embryo.
Their notebooks and
their published works
reveal that they're pretty much
exactly the same things when
they looked at blood
vessels and the heart
and the lungs and
the intestines.
So like I said, these
are some drawings
of the kinds of things they saw.
But where Haller
saw the work of God,
Wolff saw simple
mechanical, physical,
and chemical processes.
To convince Haller to try
and reconsider epigenesis,
Wolff sent him a copy
of his doctoral thesis,
which was a huge mistake.
It sparked a 10-year feud
between the two men, took up
a huge amount of time
on both of their parts,
resulted in both of them
publishing and writing
huge numbers of letters and
reviews and publications,
and of course, the
result was that each just
became more entranched in
their own belief anyway.
The feud never really was
successfully resolved.
Wolff moved to Russia
eventually, and it kind of just
petered out a little bit.
But although the correspondence
between these two men stopped,
the debate between
preformationists
and epigenesists continued
for the rest of the century.
And that high-profile feud,
along with general interest
in zoophytes and
things like polyps,
and improving technology
like microscopes,
meant that reproduction
became a really hot research
topic in the 18th century.
So let's look at a
couple of other things
that were going on in
the field at this time.
So earlier, I mentioned
two related topics.
One was spontaneous
generation, and the other
was the necessity of having
a mother and a father.
So I'm just going to talk
a little bit about how
one particular 18th-century
naturalist tried
to study those two topics.
This is Lazzaro Spallanzani.
He was an Italian priest
and a physiologist
who-- this is a statue of him
in his hometown, with a frog.
Frogs feature in this story,
as you've probably guessed.
So he was working at
the University of Pavia
in the 1760s when he got
really interested in questions
about how reproduction worked.
So he began a series
of experiments
to investigate spontaneous
generation [INAUDIBLE].
Spontaneous generation,
which as I mentioned
was a theory at least
as old as Aristotle,
was still pretty popular
in the 18th century.
One of the most famous
naturalists of the age,
who was a French
count called Buffon,
had conducted a
series of experiments
in which he made up a broth
containing wheat or gravy.
He boiled it up.
He cooled it.
He sealed the container.
He left it sit for a few
days, and as if by magic,
new microscopic life
would spontaneously
appear in the beaker.
Because Buffon was such
a well-respected figure,
a lot of people took
his results seriously
and thought they were evidence
for spontaneous generation.
But Spallanzani was
curious about this supposed
spontaneous generation, so he
set out to test those results.
He conducted
similar experiments,
but crucially, he boiled
the mixture for longer.
He took greater care to exclude
any possible contaminants.
He sealed the containers
more tightly and sooner.
And his samples didn't show
any signs of microscopic life.
So it turned out that
Buffon's method had just
been slightly flawed,
and a lot of people
believed Spallanzani's
results and considered
the matter settled.
But if life didn't
generate spontaneously,
where did it come from?
So the most common version
of preformation theory
at this time said that
the preformed germ
of a person, a
plant, or an animal
was held within
its mothers ovum.
And Spallanzani
wanted to test this.
If it was true, it meant
that male semen either
played no role at
all in conception
or that it was just
a catalyst to start
the developmental process.
So Spallanzani, in order to
test whether this was true,
designed an experiment
using frogs.
So testing reproductive theories
on humans or other animals
isn't particularly easy.
He picked the frog
because first, they
fertilize their eggs
outside the mother's body,
so you don't have to do a
huge amount of dissection
to get at their eggs.
And second, because their
eggs are large enough
to see without a
microscope quite easily.
You've probably all seen
frog spawn hanging around.
Once he had his
frogs, Spallanzani
set about making them some
tight-fitting, waterproof
trousers, which you can see.
The picture obviously
is a modern reproduction
of the experiment.
So he made some
waterproof trousers just
for the male frogs, and then
he allowed the male and female
to mate.
So the male courted
the female as usual.
He attempted to fertilize the
eggs as the mother laid them.
But due to the trousers,
none of the male frogs' semen
could reach the eggs.
So you can probably
guess what happened.
The eggs failed to
develop into tadpoles
and just withered away.
Next, undressing
his little frogs,
Spallanzani took a
couple of drops of semen
from inside their
trousers and used it
to fertilize some fresh eggs.
Now, some of these eggs grew
into healthy young tadpoles
and successfully developed
into adult frogs.
So using these
experiments, Spallanzani
was the first to show that
actually, male and female were
necessary for
animal reproduction.
And this result was used to
undermine preformation theory.
So those are a
couple of highlights
from 18th century experiments
on reproduction, all of which
originated either directly or
indirectly by people trying
to find out whether something
was an animal, a vegetable,
or a mineral.
Now, of these seven
so-called signs of life,
reproduction has been one of the
most controversial and the most
studied over the centuries.
And obviously, it's
still true today.
But just getting back to
the seven signs of life--
I started this talk with them,
and I've talked a little bit
about where they come
from, what they mean,
and how studying them can
lead to some tricky questions.
But how about today?
Well, like I said, the list
of seven characteristics
is still pretty useful for
defining those life forms
that we think about most, things
that are big enough to see,
things that kind of fall
into those classic categories
of animal or plant.
But in the last few
generations, we've
come to realize that
animals and plants make up
only really a tiny percentage
of life on this planet.
So you can see,
animals and plants
are too tiny little branches
of the phylogenetic tree
of life over there.
And bacteria is probably
the biggest group
and make up the largest amount
of biomass on the planet.
And obviously,
when you're talking
about things like
bacteria, it doesn't really
fit with the seven
characteristics of life model.
So how do you decide
that a bacteria is alive?
How do you decide that any of
those things apart from animals
and plants are alive?
So there are a couple of
modern ways of talking
about life versus non-life.
So living things, we
now say, can metabolize.
So that means that they
can use chemical reactions
to break down substances
to create energy
and to synthesize
other substances which
facilitate life.
Nowadays, we say that living
things can display homeostasis,
which means that they have a
sort of internal equilibrium
that they can
maintain themselves.
They can self-regulate
their own cells.
We say that living things can
pass on genetic information.
We say that living
things can evolve.
We say that living things
have negative entropy.
And that comes from the
laws of thermodynamics.
The second law of
thermodynamics states
that entropy tends to
increase over time,
which means that systems become
more chaotic, more disordered.
But that's not the
case living things.
They can maintain
their internal order,
and so they're said to
have negative entropy.
But a few of the classic
seven signs of life
are still pretty central
to the definition, growth
and reproduction especially.
But now, a lot of
people are of the view
that it's not possible to give
just one definition of life
or to give one a definitive
list of characteristics.
Life is much more likely to
be seen as a process rather
than a substance.
But it's still quite good fun
to ask those kinds of questions,
and I can't imagine people are
going to stop asking questions
anytime soon.
And as, I think, hopefully,
have shown today,
from very simple
questions can come
really complicated answers.
And I'll end there,
if that's all right.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
So we do have some time
for some questions.
I've got some microphones here.
Any questions for Ms. Susannah?
AUDIENCE: So you were
talking about [INAUDIBLE]
Do you think there was more of
a culture of [INAUDIBLE] back
then, or do you
think [INAUDIBLE]?
MALE SPEAKER: Susannah, can
you repeat the question?
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Oh, yes.
The question was talking
about Enlightenment culture
and people replicating
experiments themselves.
The question was, do you think
citizen science was bigger
in the 18th century or today?
Certainly, you can see with
something like the experiment
of the polyp, it's really easy.
You go to your local
pond, you pick up a polyp,
you cut it in two.
You don't even need a
microscope to see a polyp.
A magnifying glass
might be helpful,
but you don't even need that.
So it's incredibly
simple, whereas today,
the kind of experiments that
you hear about in the news--
the Large Hadron
Collider and things
like that-- they are a lot
more difficult to recreate.
I think today,
education policy is
sort of pushing kids
into much more sort
of systematic ways of learning.
You're less encouraged
to run around
ponds gathering up slime and
seeing what happens with it.
Or those chemistry sets we
used to have as kids-- really
dangerous things in them.
I think they're a lot more
closely regulated nowadays.
But certainly,
Enlightenment culture really
encouraged people
to question things,
to try things out
for themselves.
And a lot of the people
I've spoken about today
are quite elite scientists.
A lot of them were
members of academies,
like the World Society
in London or Paris.
But actually, there were huge
numbers of working-class people
involved in this kind of thing.
There were a lot of working
men forming botanical clubs.
There were zoological clubs, who
would put their money together
and buy a library for
themselves and keep in the pub
or something like that.
So all across society, a
lot of people were, I think,
much more interested in
science and basic science
than they are today.
Thank you for the question.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Any other
questions for Susannah?
AUDIENCE: If I could just make a
comment rather than a question,
it's been really
interesting that you've
taught these
scientists' names to us
today, because I'm really only
familiar with van Leeuwenhoek--
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Oh,
Leeuwenhoek, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --who developed the
microscope in the [INAUDIBLE]
century, I think.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: 17th century.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, 1600s.
And Robert Hooke was
his contemporary.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I really
appreciate the fact
that you've introduced
these names that I
haven't known before today.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Well,
thank you very much.
And I realized halfway
through the talk
I hadn't spelt a lot of
the names, which actually
is something I always get really
cross about when speakers don't
do that.
So if you want to know any
of the spellings of names
or anything, just have
a flick through the book
or come and ask me later.
But thank you very
much for the comment.
MALE SPEAKER: There's
a question here.
AUDIENCE: Is a piece of coral
considered an animal, or just
an individual polyp?
SUSANNAH GIBSON:
That's a good question.
I'll repeat the question.
The question was, is a coral
considered an animal or just
a polyp?
So they're kind of
a colony of animals.
So within one coral, you'll have
thousands of individual polyps.
Each policy secretes-- they
kind of act like a snail.
They make a hard shell
around themselves,
and when you join thousands
of these things together,
they form what looks
like a coral to us.
So it's quite a
difficult question
to answer, because
in a way a coral does
act a bit like a plant,
because the colony of animals
all joins together and
support each other.
And if you just had
one living on its own,
it probably wouldn't
fare that well.
And also, to just get
back to my disclaimer,
I'm not a scientist.
But it's a good question.
Does anyone else know
the answer to that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] similar
to an ant colony can't survive.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Yeah,
an individual ant
can't do that well on its own.
Absolutely.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think we have
time for one more question,
and then we're going to
have some [INAUDIBLE].
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I have
[INAUDIBLE] question.
Obviously you mentioned that-- I
forgot their names, Wolff and--
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Haller.
AUDIENCE: --both came with
identical observations,
but came up with different
conclusions because
of their religious
background and what
they brought [INAUDIBLE].
Is there an acknowledgement
within the science community,
we'll call it the history
of science, as to what
people [INAUDIBLE] personally
and how that influences
their results, and how to
get over that or around that?
SUSANNAH GIBSON:
That probably is
one of the biggest topics that
comes up in history of science
over and over again.
And the fact is, because
science is a human activity,
it's kind of inherently flawed.
And everyone comes to
science with an agenda.
And there is the
idea that there is
such thing as the
scientific method
and it's completely impartial.
And on paper it is,
but in reality, science
is being done with
people, and they're
being funded by people who want
particular things from them.
I know someone who is working
for a large and unnamed tobacco
company, working
out whether or not
tobacco plants have certain
concentrations of carcinogenic
chemicals in them.
But her research is
being funded by someone
who wants a particular answer.
And that's kind of an
extreme example of that case,
but even in the
most impartial lab,
people often approach
an experiment
with the result in mind.
People often start off
an experiment thinking,
oh, I think it's
probably a 90% chance
that it will lead to this.
And often, if that result
doesn't come about,
people just try it
over and over and over
until-- it takes an
awfully long time,
I think, for people to give
up their preconceptions.
when
I started off as a scientist
but now I'm a historian,
and it gives you such a
different view science,
seeing how, through
the last 2,000 years,
people have shaped their
answers to what society wanted
from them and to
their own religious
and social and
philosophical beliefs.
I think it would be quite
hard as a working scientist.
I think you have to be a
realist as a working scientist.
There is a right answer.
But when you take
time to step back,
you see it as a human activity.
It's really interesting.
And as a historian,
that makes work
much, much more interesting
on a day-to-day basis.
It's much more
interesting seeing
people who came up with what
you might call a bad theory,
and why they wanted
to believe that
and what they got
out of it, I think.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Thank you, Rob.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great.
So please join me
in giving Susannah
another round-of-applause.
SUSANNAH GIBSON: Thank you.